It's true that you could use a normal resolution
image in the source and then replace it with javascript
with a higher resolution image. when you programtically detect
the device pixel ratios greater than one. However ,this means
that you would be downloading the normal image and
then a high density image ,on all high density devices.
And unfortunately, most of the current high density devices, that
is where device pixel ratio is set higher to one,
our mobile devices, like my phone and my tablet
,where bandwidth is probably at a premium. So ,this
isn't really a good solution for any reason except
simplicity. It is possible though, that this will be
solved on a server side .For the device pixel
ratio scenario particularly, by something called client-hints. Client-hints is
a header sent to the sever to let it
know what device pixel ratio you're rendering at and
what size you're actually looking for. It uses the vary header to let it know
that the version shouldn't be reused by caches
improperly. However, client hiddence isn't broadly implemented and
deployed yet. And, this approach won't necessarily
solve everything about responsive images. However, once this
approach is actually implemented broadly, it will definitely
be a great tool for fixing density issues.
For now though, you need to make the
decisions on the client side and ask the server
for the right image for your device pixel
ratio. Except remember, its not just device pixel ratio.